i think our gut is always stronger than
anyone else's
advice and our gut will tell us what the
right advice is to listen to oh
this is what jamie did when someone said
no
no one's going to buy makeup from
someone who looks like you because of
your body and weight
this is how she handled staring fear and
rejection straight in the eye
and i knew in that one shot we were
either going to my
whole life would be changed or we were
going to go bankrupt
and out of business where i come from
doesn't have to determine where i'm
going
jimmy carter michael how are you i'm
great how are you
so good look at your blanket so i i
so jamie sent me this blanket after
after our puerto rico
visit i guess it's been over a year now
and i love it because it says believe
in it and and believe is her her most
important core value she's got it here
new book believe it just came out
amazing believe it's my one word too and
uh
anyway i thought this is the nicest
blanket we've ever gotten
my wife usually takes it every night uh
and you know have the dogs in her lab
when we watch a show but i got to take
it for this episode so i can
i can look like i'm from game of thrones
or something let's put it on
you know it's the craziest blanket so
this blanket evan
when we so after three years of hearing
no from everyone on the planet trying to
build my company and like getting down
there last few dollars we finally got a
shot on qvc
and i ended up you know doing over a
thousand live shows on qvc so i was
literally almost living in the green
room for eight years and i would
take that blanket the exact blanket you
have over your shoulders
there would be days i could barely get
through like
a you know another 20-hour day live and
i was like okay so i'd read customer
letters and i'd wrap up in that blanket
in the green room and so it's like my
favorite thing to share with my friends
and and family because it's just can't
you i mean how would you describe it it
kind of feels like you're
i know you're like i'm bad like game of
thrones but doesn't it kind of feel like
you're wrapped in love a little bit
it's like a cloud it's just it's the
softest banquet that i've ever seen
anyway so my wife and i use it every
single day super blessed thank you for
sending it over
um ladies and gentlemen if you don't
know jamie curran lima
she went from having less than a
thousand dollars in her bank account
to starting a luxury cosmetics company
to then selling it for 1.2
billion dollars and she's the author of
believe it right here we're going to
link it up to the youtube audience we'll
put the link in description below
go check it out um it's great to have
you i mean i know you've been you've
been doing some crazy
crazy crazy crazy crazy crazy
i've done a lot of things this week that
i have never done before
evan a lot of things this week i have
never
done before um yeah we did a live event
um monday you'd be so proud of me
because we streamed it on youtube
you'd be so proud of me wait louise do
you have your own youtube channel now
i do officially as of this week i know i
was like evan's going to be so proud of
me
we'll talk after we have to talk this is
exciting
everyone in the world like like the the
biggest thought leaders in the world
that they all turn to evan
for advice on everything especially
everything youtube and so yeah
literally when when i created it this
week i was like oh evan's gonna i
thought of you you're gonna be so proud
of me so we streamed the event to
youtube and
we had uh 216 000 people sign up for the
event
live on the day and it was so special
and
first ever live event first ever youtube
channel first ever live with evan
carmichael on instagram
it's a big week first ever book first
ever book
it's a big week evan so this is the
place that i want to take this but
i want to start with oprah yeah
talk to me about the importance of oprah
in your life especially growing up
um yeah growing up
uh well always as a little girl i'd sit
in my living room and watch
and watch her on television and it was
how i knew like oh one day
i'd watch her interview other people and
share their stories with the world and i
thought that's
that's the coolest thing and um i uh
her showing sharing her pain sharing her
i mean at the time she was doing this
there was no social media right people
weren't
sharing their stories behind their
stories
and she was one of the first people that
went out there and said
like let me bear my soul and reveal
all the stuff that most people are
embarrassed about embarrassed to share
embarrassed to ashamed of and she really
um
i think did that and i remember i don't
remember this moment but it was nine
years old
i was nine years old when she was
interviewed by barbara walters and uh
and she said to her on national
television she said i always knew
i was destined for greatness and i
remember after oprah said that i
remember evan sitting there as a little
girl going
i know that feeling like that feeling
that a lot of us have inside of us like
we're made for more and if we can just
break through our own self-doubt
uh right like like we know we have
things to give the world or to create or
to offer or to inspire
i remember having that feeling as a
little girl when i heard her say that
and i also remember she got a ton of
backlash in the press for it
because a lot of people weren't used to
somebody especially a woman but
somebody's saying like
i'm destined for greatness and i've
always had this feeling so when she said
that i remember
you know watching the media's response
to that but i also remember connecting
with it
and i think like one of the things
that's so inspiring about what you do
evan carmichael every single day is like
you
you also inspire other people to believe
right and
and for me growing up that's what that's
what oprah did for me and so
i had no idea i would one day meet her i
had no idea she'd become a real life
mentor in my life
um she was one of the very first people
to read my book cover to cover
i wanted her blessing on it because
there's some stuff i share in there that
like 95 of this book believe it is stuff
i've never shared before
and uh so there's some oprah stuff in
there and i wanted her
her blessing before i share it so yeah
she's um
you know in all the days i was at
denny's waitress and working at safeway
grocery store pushing shopping carts i
don't know if i could have ever
dreamed um that i would even just be
here live with you
you know i i don't know that i could
have even imagined this
dreamed of this being here with you uh
or saying to you these words oprah was
the first person
to read the book like yeah but i made a
decision to believe it
which is you know i think it's time for
everyone we've been in a dark season
it's been a tough 14 months for
a lot of people and a lot of us have let
our light dim
we've forgotten to believe in ourselves
we've forgotten we have a light inside
of us at all
so my whole hope and prayer for this
book is it reignites
that light and that ability and and
just self-belief again because a lot of
people need to start dreaming again
and believing that things are possible
one of my favorite oprah stories from
believe it is about to go on qvc
and you're stressing out because you
only have 10 minutes and and you've
bought all this inventory just kind of
make a break and
you want to do it your way and show real
people and show your your real face with
the
skin issues that you had and everybody's
telling you no it's the wrong thing and
you drive to the parking lot and you're
sitting outside qvc
and then you imagine oprah
and color purple and how she manifested
that
take us a little deeper into that story
yeah
um i feel like thank you for asking that
question i feel like there's probably
people that follow you and their stories
you share
and then they grab onto those right and
they tap in we can all tap into
other people's stories to give us
strength
um and it's really why i wrote this book
too is because i
my prayers all the stories and struggles
and lessons i've gone through
hopefully someone else can grab onto
those and use them in their own
in their own journey so yeah one of
those big stories after three years
of hearing know from all the beauty
retailers all the department stores
right i created
a product that i believed in and a lot
of people watching us right now maybe
that are entrepreneurs or that are
creating something
and maybe you're in a space where you're
like not getting the traction
you hoped or you're having people tell
you no or not believe in you
that was my journey for uh three years
so
everyone had been telling us no qvc had
said no
time after time after time and we
finally got this big break evan finally
got this big break
and we were gonna get one shot on qvc
and it meant we had this 10 minute
window
uh to either sell our product and hit
the sales goal or not come back
right and just to give everyone a little
bit of context um qvc's live
television shopping channel broadcast to
100 million homes
um and uh and at the time evan
we were just we were still just selling
two to three orders a day on our website
barely staying alive three years into
the business
hearing no after no after no after no
not knowing if we're gonna make it
and we get this one shot to go live in
this 10 minute window
and so i'm like okay and then i learned
it's a consignment deal
which means uh which means that we're
not paid so we have to
we have to pay for all the inventory
right to make it
ship it in and then we go on air and
we're only paid for what
sells and um i learned then that we
would need to do over
sell over 6 000 units of our product
to hit the sales goal in a 10-minute
window so 6 000 units in this 10-minute
window
meanwhile evan i'm like you know eating
like like it was a date night me and my
husband would have a date night
if it was like the one dollar hot dogs
at costco and i don't know if you've
ever been to a costco in the outdoor hot
dog stand
and you go there and it's a dollar for a
hot dog and they're good hot dogs but
like
that's as fancy as we i mean we were
down right and
and so to figure out okay wow
everything's on the line for our
business
you know we have to figure out how we
had to uh borrow money
we got we got turned away from 22 banks
it was the 23rd bank that said yes
um which is a small bank in california
gave us an sba loan just to cover the
amount of inventory
to do this one airing on qvc so
everything was on the line and i was
like oh my gosh i
i it was so much for me to handle um
it felt so heavy and i flew out to qvc
which is just outside of philadelphia
a week before we got this one shot to go
live
and i knew in that one shot we were
either going
my whole life would be changed uh or
we were gonna go bankrupt and out of
business and it felt so heavy and here's
why
um we hired third-party consultants
who are amazing at helping people sell
on television and sell their products
and stores and all those things and they
change they help so many people and they
all told me the same
thing they said if you're going to have
a shot at succeeding in this 10-minute
window
here's what you need to do you need to
put this type of model on the air
which was all women with perfect skin
and i said to them but the authentic
reason i started this company is because
i don't have perfect same like i have
bright red rosacea it gets bumpy
everywhere and i'm like
you know i created this product because
there's so many people out there like me
who can't find anything that works i'm
like qvc is live
you can't fake it you can't photoshop it
i'm like i want to go on
television and like prove it live you
have to remember evan this is before
instagram live this is before youtube
right
and i was like and no one was doing this
i'm like let me just take my makeup off
and show my bright red rosacea let me
prove live
how this product works and and i had
this vision of putting real women of all
different ages and shapes and sizes and
skin tones and skin problems and all
this stuff
and let me show live on them and
these expert consultants were mortified
like they're like listen
and they they wanted the best for me but
they're like
if you you know you're you're getting
one shot and we want you to win
and here's what you need to do you need
to put this type women will only buy
makeup
from people who have perfect skin who
they'll never be able to look like
and so i was being told this message and
i feel like
every one of us in our life we have
moments in our life
where our gut instinct is telling us one
thing
and other people are telling us another
other
experts are telling us another other
you know people's opinions are or or the
world
that maybe we're not having success in
our business yet that lack of traction
makes us feel like maybe our gut
instincts wrong so
the moment you're talking about i i flew
out a week ahead of time a week before
this 10-minute window i sat in the qvc
parking lot and i sat in this rental car
all alone and i st i just stared at the
front door of qvc and i knew the next
time i walked through that door
my whole life was gonna change or i was
gonna be bankrupt and my whole life was
gonna change for that
that way and i just sat there praying
and crying and then
uh it felt heavy and i felt like okay
it's easy in life for us to know what we
stand for
but then like often our values are put
on the line
do you know what i mean and i was in
this moment of going and honestly
self-doubt started to enter my head and
like
i had thoughts of like oh well i don't
want to go bankrupt so maybe if i listen
to them and do it their way
the the third party consultants if i do
it their way
to start with and then i have success
and then i try it my way i had all these
thoughts
but i also know you can't fake
authenticity i
also know the second you show up as
who other people want you to be you
create a barrier of disconnection
between you
and any other human being including an
audience including your customers right
so i knew that um and i sat in that car
freaking out every day for a week and i
prayed and i cried and then i'm like
what would oprah do i remember her i
remember a show where she said she
wanted the color purple so bad that she
ran around a track and was praying the
song i surrender all and crying and
so i started singing i surrender all and
i literally asked god to take it from me
because it felt so heavy
and i also just remembered who is this
person i'm talking to
uh if i'm gonna have one shot in 10
minutes on qvc
like i imagine for some reason i kept
imagining a single mom
like folding laundry who was too busy
to remember that she mattered and too
busy to remember that she's beautiful
and
i just thought about like if i was going
to get the blessing of two seconds of
her time and she was going to turn on a
television and see me live on qvc
i wanted her to look up and see other
women who look like her
and see me calling them beautiful and
meaning it even if she
didn't buy a single thing you know what
i mean like i
wanted to stand for something then sell
a ton of
product and stand for nothing and that's
really what it came down to but
sometimes we know we know what we need
to do
but when it's the hard thing it's hard
and um
i walked in in that building for that
that 10-minute airing
and it was like one of the scariest
things i've ever done because it just
felt so heavy um
i was dripping sweat everywhere i was a
hot mess to be honest
and like i wasn't nervous for television
but i was nervous
that my whole company was on the line
and i remember the 10-minute clock start
and it was like
9 59 9 58 and we were live and
in front of 100 million homes and i
remember the moment my my bright red
bare face
before shot came up and then we walked
over to all the models and i showed
all different women of different ages
and skin tones and skin skin
types and all sizes and shapes and i
remember there was about a minute left
in
in the presentation and the host started
saying the shades were selling out the
deep shade is down to 100 units in the
tan and i was just like
and then when the the 10-minute mark hit
and uh
the sold out sign came right up across
yes
that moment that moment right there i
literally started sobbing
34 everybody
so um you know i'm i i think that in
life
and listen i've learned so much from
experts i continue to every single day i
am a lifetime student
and anytime i get advice from an expert
i think it's so important or anybody a
friend a family member
i think it's so important we check in
with our gut and go is that advice right
for me
and i think our gut is always stronger
than anyone else's
advice and our gut will tell us what the
right advice is to listen to
and um and that was a life-changing
moment for me
um on the page you just showed and um
when i look back at so many of the
mistakes i made they were when i didn't
listen to my
my own gut and started to second guess
myself and
a big reason i wrote believe it is
really just to talk about
how how do you go from because you know
my story a lot of people think oh it's
denny's waitress turned billion dollar
entrepreneur but my my real story is a
girl who didn't believe in herself and
and and figured out how to
and and didn't trust myself and learn
how to
tune in and hear my own intuition and
trust it and i just know it's the story
of so many other people out there right
now
watching us live right now um
who i see in the comments and we're all
on this journey in life i think of
really learning as you would say evan to
believe
to believe in in ourself and everything
else so
thank you for having me i'm talking a
lot i'm so tired right now and delirious
from this book launch week
that i'm just like evan carmichael i'll
just
thank you for having me on by the way
thank you for your friendship too
i don't know if everyone knows who's
watching but you really
um help uplift so many other people and
it's
it's fun to watch you to watch you do
that your heart is so
is so amazing so just want to call that
out
thank you for that i uh what does lisa
nichols say she i gave her a compliment
she said
i i received that i received your
compliment
it's like thank you i like that i
receive your message jamie thank you
um why i brought up oprah was because it
i think when people are watching you
you've kind of come out of nowhere in
terms of the thought leadership
space which is amazing like a year ago
people didn't
really know who you were necessarily
outside of the beauty industry and now
like
she's everywhere which is fantastic but
like authenticity is the word that just
keeps coming over and over and over
again and your
your your courage your willingness to to
bear it all and share your story
it's what i what i think of what you did
in the in the beauty industry
reminds me of what oprah would have done
if she was in the beauty industry
there's like that through line of i
guess still what would oprah do
um so i just thought it was curious that
she was your kind of hero or one of your
heroes growing up and
sitting there in the car thinking about
the color purple
does that resonate like i think if oprah
was gonna go makeup
she would have it be the every woman on
the show
not just the fancy models yeah and i
think that
her whole life is about authenticity you
know one of the things um absolutely it
resonates yeah thank you by the way for
saying that that's like the biggest
compliment in the world and
you know um yeah the whole personal
growth space i mean
i remember 20 years ago i was a waitress
at denny's and i would save my tip money
at denny's to buy tony robbins personal
power tapes and
attend my first ever seminar and
i've always loved and believed like it
helped me then believe that where i
i come from doesn't have to determine
where i'm going and
i i love i just feel like i'm a lifetime
student with everyone else and
you know i went through a decade of
starting a business
with nothing and going through years and
years of rejection and then figuring out
how to turn
every no that i faced how to not take
those no's personal
there was some personal no's but how did
not take them personal
how to turn them into yeses and went
through the process of
building a team of over a thousand
people leading departments made a lot of
mistakes i worked hundred hour weeks for
close to a decade and
there's things i would do differently um
and you know then we went through the
process of
the acquisition process so l'oreal
acquired our our business for
um in this all-cash deal in 2016 for 1.2
billion dollars and
went through the whole exit process and
you know i
i feel like why i wrote this book why it
might feel like i'm popping up out of
nowhere
because there's a lot of people that are
amazing at
motivation and inspiration and i think
for me
i've actually been heads down
like building a business for a decade
right in the sense of like
all the rejection the resiliency making
lots of mistakes and then doing lots of
things right and
you know i had this big realization
about two years ago
for five years i would have different
lit agents approaching
me to do a book and i always said no
because they're like we can get you a
ghostwriter and i'm like
you know no i i know that you can't fake
authenticity and if i ever do it
i want to pour my heart and soul into it
i want it to matter i want it to be
you know everything i wish i'd known
that would have saved me
a lot of self-doubt that would have
saved me a lot of nights crying myself
to sleep
and so i always said no to doing a book
or a movie all that stuff and then about
two years ago
i realized something i realized that
every single day on instagram
i was getting messages i was getting dms
from people saying
oh my gosh you know congrats on your
business and all this but like
did you just get lucky or like did you
have a lot of connections because
i'm not getting traction in my business
and i'm getting rejected and i'm very
i'm embarrassed to ever tell anyone
about it
i'm thinking about quitting all those
things right and i realized
evan that oh my gosh like everything
i've gone through
in the past decade but also in my whole
life
if we keep it inside of us and we don't
share it like
like then people just see the highlight
reel and when people
google my story they just see denny's
waitress builds a billion dollar
entrepreneur or builds billion dollar
business right
and then people feel alone in their own
struggles and in their own setbacks and
then their own
you know everything and i was like okay
i think that if i actually
share all the real stories behind the
stories
um that maybe it'll help other people on
their own journey
like oh this is what jamie did when
someone said
no no one's gonna buy makeup from
someone who looks like you because of
your body and weight
this is how she handled staring fear and
rejection
straight in the eye and keeping her
faith bigger than it like
i share so many stories in here that
aren't for me
you know i'm donating 100 of the
proceeds from the book 100
to uh feeding america and to together
rising i just i literally wrote this i
wrote every single one of the 80 000
words in it
because i just felt like um
you know i think everything we all go
through
when when we can make it about something
other than ourselves when we can make it
about something
bigger than ourselves when it can help
other people that's really where our
fulfillment
comes um whether it's little things we
do every day or
or big things like writing a book so
that's really why i wrote it so it's so
funny
because that because uh you're like you
come out of nowhere i'm like
oh my gosh i've been doing 100 hour
weeks for 10 years like
i think i think it's been this this
crazy journey
um and and by the way you know uh this
started by
literally evan i don't know if anyone
knows the story but
when i knew i knew it was time to write
the book i knew it was time to step away
from the company i built in my living
room and it was so hard i loved the team
like like family right we built over a
thousand employees and
across the country and and world um and
so uh three days after it was three days
how many days i don't know how many days
after leaving
the business i was like okay i want to
just do something i love let me go to a
personal growth event
and i bought tickets to brendon
burchard's event had never met him
and brought a couple women i mentor i
mentor a lot of other women
and friends and i did these these
tickets to the event
and he had a speaker fall through a
couple days before the event and he sent
a group text out to his friends and he's
like does anyone know of a
you know a great speaker somebody had uh
nominated me and
he and i end up getting on a phone call
he's like could you hop on stage and do
an
hour keynote speech there's no script no
teleprompter nothing
you're just there's a few thousand
people in the audience you'll be live
can you just hop on stage
and do an hour keynote so i'm freaking
out i don't know brendan right i don't
know i'm on the phone with him
and i'm like absolutely like yep for
sure
and then inside i'm like oh crap like
like i'm like freaking out
um and then i tell him i'm like well i
don't know if you know this but i'm
actually i already have tickets to the
event so i'm gonna be there anyway he's
like what
he's like what i'm like yeah yeah i
bought tickets
i'm bringing a couple women i mentor
we're sitting the audience and he's like
you're you're in like it's this funniest
thing like the most serendipitous thing
and that day i hopped on this is
talking about popping up in the personal
growth space but
i hopped on his stage and and did our
keynote
all of us were sobbing yes that picture
so this picture i totally forgot this
evan in this moment
this picture because so simon and
schuster want me to do like a
professional photo shoot right which is
what you do as an author a proper photo
shoot
i'm like you know what what if we just
share a live moment reel where
where where in real connection with
other human beings
this that day i'm talking about is so
funny you're so smart i mean oh my gosh
this is why everyone gets advice from
you
so this day was on his stage
i popped up live did the did the hour
keynote
were all laughing crying together in the
audience and
and yeah a picture taken by maggie
maggie kirkland uh who was there just
snapped this photo and
like let's use a real moment um so
that was really fun then i got off of
the stage and
and brendan came over a couple days
later met my husband my daughter and
uh and that was i guess almost two years
ago year and a half ago
and now i talk to brendan every single
day and now he's one of my closest
friends and
amazing and uh a few months ago tony
robbins asked me to speak at business
mastery and
then he and i ended up doing three hours
live together
uh which wasn't planned and um and so
that was a big full circle moment
especially going back to the denny's
days where i would say my tip money to
buy his
tapes and so it's it's been a wild
year it might feel new but it also kind
of feels like you know i think
everything we do in our life
um even when we don't see it in the
moment the setbacks the hard times the
things that suck the things that aren't
fair
i feel like they're all set ups in the
long term for
how strong we need to be and for what
we're supposed to do
on the next step of our journey i love
it
do you have time for one quick activity
sure
let's do it i don't know what it is but
let's go
actually i'm trusting my gut this is it
so
i i want to do from jamie
a quick prayer
and and what i want to do is we'll close
our eyes and everybody watching close
your eyes
and just if you could think back to who
you used to be or like who
who believe it is really meant for the
person who's struggling to believe in
themselves they're struggling to have
the confidence they have big ideas bold
ambitions
but they're they just need that extra
reminder
of who they are that they can do it and
and i see this honestly as something
that whenever somebody is feeling
low down uh unsure themselves they could
fast forward
to watch this part of the video again to
get that personal message
from jamie are you down
i'm down so this is going to be a prayer
for
every single person listening no matter
what faith they practice
or if they have no faith or if they
trust the universe
so i want to make sure because i'll use
the words i use when i pray
but i just want to know everyone's
welcome into this prayer no matter how
they pray or if they pray at all no
matter what they believe or if they
don't believe
when you see my friends in life my
closest
group of friends i actually talk a lot
about this in the book about how do you
build that circle around you
um they don't all pray the same or vote
the same or love the same or believe the
same but they all have huge hearts
and i think in life like um
that's how we should attract people
that's why i'm honored to be your friend
mr evan carmichael because you have a
big heart and so
i just want to say that so thank you so
all right you ready
we're ready we're ready people people
are crying already in the in
the comments you know what that tells me
that tells me uh
that they're supposed to be here with us
right now so
all right i'm going to close my eyes too
then
dear god i just want to ask that you
bless
every single person listening right now
watching right now hearing this
right now i do not think it's an
accident
that they're hearing this right now and
that they're showing up or that they're
watching this video or that they're
hearing these words
and i just ask that you remind them of
who they are of who
they were born to be long before
people around them told them something
else long before the world around them
told them how they weren't enough or how
they needed to change
who they are to fit in and i just want
you to
spark that light inside of them that
reminds them
that they have every single thing
inside of them right now so if you're
listening right now
and you're watching this right now i
just want to remind you
you have every single thing you need
inside of you right now
to become the person you're born to be
and everything in you is perfect
you don't need to change anything about
who you are
right the second you do that you step
away the real victory
is becoming all of who you are and all
of the person you're born to be and i
just want to pray that every single
person listening right now
who might be in the midst of a setback
in the midst of a
season where they're feeling doubt or
things aren't going their way
or they're just feeling like i'm stuck
and
lost and like they don't belong right
like they're not enough
i just want to pray that they take in
these words right now
especially for people feeling like
they're not
qualified or they don't have what it
takes
words that i love every single day that
i'm going to share in this prayer
right now god doesn't call the qualified
he qualifies the called anyone right now
feeling like they don't have what it
takes
is just not true like if god doesn't
call the qualified he qualifies the
called
it means if you have a dream on your
heart a purpose you're feeling like
going after
something you just can't shake even if
you're not having the success you want
right now
if you feel in your gut that you're
supposed to be doing it
whether it's painting the painting or
dancing and taking the ballroom dance
class or putting yourself out there
online or writing the first page of the
book
god doesn't call it qualified he
qualifies the call it means you have
every single thing inside of you you
need right now
to accomplish your wildest dreams and
the greatest journey we can go on in
life is learning to believe that
for ourselves so god i just want to say
i pray belief into every person
listening right now i do not think it's
an accident they're hearing this or
listening to this
and i just want to thank you in advance
because it's already done
in jesus name amen
so evan carmichael i have never done a
prayer on
instagram live on facebook live on
youtube
anywhere that was a first you put me on
the spot but i'm like listen
listen i show up for you and i hope i
showed up for everyone else because
i know this is not about me this is
about anyone listening right now who
needs to hear this into their life and
we're all in this life together that's
the biggest thing a lot of people are
feeling alone right now
and what a blessing the work you do evan
which is bringing people together even
in a virtual format because a lot of
people are alone right now and they're
struggling and they're
they're they need this right now they
need to believe so thank you for
putting that goodness that force for
good out into the world every day
well i had no idea that we were gonna do
that either or just it came to me
don't don't quench the spirit right let
it flow
ladies and gentlemen jamie curling of
the book is believe it
youtube will link it up in the
description below so excited that you
can join us for this so excited that you
wrote the book so excited that you are
being you and just
such a forceful good in the world and
for joining us here on this
video interview appreciate you jamie
thanks for popping in i appreciate you
so much thank you so much evan thank you
everyone
take care eat you if you want to see the
one-on-one i did with marie forleo check
out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there modern
entrepreneurship can be for everyone
all of us are immersed in a culture that
has taught
us that non-stop work is the most
valuable thing
the brain needs breaks